hey GameSpot we've got a destiny to clip
for you running in 4k on PC we know that
many of you don't have a 4k monitor and
to be honest destiny was always a
good-looking game so probably won't look
that different to you that being said
what's different in this clip is that we
were playing on a mouse and keyboard and
messing around with the new power class
of weapons like the grenade launcher the
more precise aiming let us do things
like target explosive tanks on the back
of cabal incendios yes that's what
they're actually called the PC release
is confirmed for October 24th and I'm
wondering how many of you are going to
wait for the potentially better-looking
version first jumping in over a month
earlier on console let us know in the
comments below and give us the old like
and subscribe so that we can get you
more destiny to coverage let's get to it
Zavala picked up that Guardian you never
shut up about oh hold on back there
come on big guy
do something
[Music]
alright Guardian time to Kingdom where
dirt
[Music]
okay the shield generator should be at
the bottom of the ship
hey what's your status ah no ah mo saw
flaming kick kept burning out demons
from Acorah nuts it's one for the
speaker for me
[Music]
you